okay today I'm going to talk to you
about pollutants we're gonna have a look
at five different pollutants how they're
formed and the impact that it can have
on the environment so whenever we burn
hydrocarbons such as fuels we produce
pollutants the first example we're going
to look at is carbon dioxide now carbon
dioxide chemical formula is co2 dioxide
meaning two oxygens so how is it formed
basically it's formed through the
complete combustion of a hydrocarbon
this just means when there's a plentiful
supply of oxygen now the impact that
carbon dioxide has is as follows because
carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas it
absorbs infrared radiation and this
causes an increase in temperature so
this causes a phenomenon referred to as
global warming which I'm sure you've
heard of due to the fact that this
infrared radiation is absorbed by carbon
dioxide it caused an increase in global
temperature now the negative side of
that is it basically is leading to the
ice caps melting now if my ice caps melt
not only is it bad for the animals that
live in those particular regions such as
polar bears but it's a problem globally
because it causes rising sea levels
across the world which basically can
cause flooding so it causes those sea
levels to rise across the globe
the next pollutant we need to know about
is carbon monoxide now the formula for
that one is just C O so mono oxide
meaning one oxygen now how this is
formed is instead of complete combustion
of a hydrocarbon
it's from incomplete combustion there's
actually a separate video about the
differences between these two types of
combustion now carbon monoxide is
clean nasty substance it's a toxic
odorless colorless gas which means you
can't smell it and you can't see it
making it extremely dangerous now it's
extremely extremely toxic because what
it does is it stops red blood cells in
your body from carrying oxygen and that
causes you to suffocate so if it hit
here's a red blood cell
normally it would carry o to around the
body to every cell
what carbon monoxide does is it binds to
the red blood cell and it stops the
oxygen from binding to the red blood
cell so that's why it's so so dangerous
if you have a lodged if you have enough
of a high dose of this it will kill you
next up we have certs
you might also hear this being called
particulates of carbon or particles of
carbon essentially it's just carbon
atoms again this is formed from
incomplete combustion of a hydrocarbon
when there's an insufficient supply of
oxygen
now basically soot is that kind of nasty
black stuff that you get when when
something's when something burns when
you burn a hydrocarbon so it's that
horrible black dust now what it can do
is it can make buildings dirty if you've
ever seen loads of buildings that are
right next to a really really busy road
in a big city they're often quite
blackened and that's from all of the
soot due to the incomplete combustion
and all of the carbon coming from the
cars exhausts it basically reduces air
quality and it can also cause
respiratory problems so those are
problems with your respiratory system so
I just draw a little diagram of the
lungs right here
then hopefully that should be a nice
demonstration of another problem caused
by certs okay now moving on the next
pollutant that we need to know about is
sulphur dioxide so this is so2
now what sulphur dioxide is is formed
from it's actually within fuels there
are these things called sulfur
impurities so within fuels there's
little bits of sulfur that we don't
really need to be there they just within
the fuel so what happens is when we burn
those those hydrocarbons that contain
sulfur impurities we're making sulfur
dioxide now what that sulfur dioxide
then does is it mixes with the water
vapor in clouds to produce dilute
sulfuric acid and that acid can then
fall down from the skies so the big
impact is this phenomenon called acid
rain so it's literally dilute sulfuric
acid raining down from the clouds now
the big problem the still it can cause
first of all it can kill trees so the
trees obviously are outside they're
exposed to lots of this salt dilute
sulfuric acid and kill trees also if it
goes into lakes it can basically acidify
the lakes so it can also kill and kill
wildlife particularly let's say fish
that are in the legs so it can kill lots
of those are fish that are within lakes
it can also damage statues so if they're
statues particularly made of things like
limestone the acid can react with the
limestone and cause corrosion and damage
those things like statues and other
buildings in fact so the final polluter
we need
to look at a once called oxides of
nitrogen now the formula for this one
looks a bit weird because we've just put
NO X that's because this could be this
could be a number one oxygen two oxygens
or three oxygens it just depends on what
we form but all of these different
oxides of nitrogen all have a particular
impact so how are these formed so
basically whenever we have combustion
occurring for example in an engine of a
car we have really high temperatures and
when we have really high temperatures we
can have nitrogen and oxygen just which
already exists in the air reacting
together so it's due to the high
temperatures within the combustion
engine for example that nitrogen oxygen
from the air react together to make
these oxides of nitrogen so the bigger
prop big problem associated with oxides
of nitrogen is photochemical smog
photochemical smog so you might have
seen this before in certain cities it's
a type of air pollution it looks a bit
like fog but it's produced from the from
oxides of nitrogen and the problem you
can get with this is breathing
difficulties it can also affect
visibility within cities so those are
the five pollutions we need to know
about
that's the formation how they're formed
and this is the impact they have on the
environment thank you